je suis Benoît Hamon vous allez bien oui
ça va tu fais campagne pour les
élections européennes revenir au contact
des trappistes pour les informer des
élections européennes le 26 mai prochain
le principe de ce porte à porte organisé
par Benoît Hamon et son mouvement
génération point S un retour sur ses
anciennes terres lui le député de la 11e
circonscription des Yvelines entre 2012
et 2017 j'ai toujours une bonne relation
avec la plupart des habitants de cette
ville c'est c'est on a une et même au
législatives j'ai perdu aux hélicatives
mais à Trappes j'étais largement en tête
sur la ville pas sur la circonscription
donc il y a toujours une relation un peu
assez forte avec les habitants de cette
ville à ses côtés notamment des élus
locaux à l'irabet adjoint chargé des
sports sur la commune de trappes et
Bertrand Houillon maire de
Magny-les-Hameaux
100% social 100% écologique et voilà
100% européenne j'accompagne Benoît
Hamon puisque je crois foncièrement à
une Europe qui soit plus sociale qui
soit plus juste pour les qui assure la
liberté des citoyens des citoyens après
le porte-à-porte place au meeting près
de 400 personnes présentes dans la salle
Jean-Baptiste Clément la plupart des
militants de la première heure c'est
cette propositions de gauche je le
soutiens depuis le début ce sont des
valeurs de gauche voilà donc je soutiens
son programme à fond oui effectivement
oui nous on est clairement pour l'Europe
on est pour la gauche on est pour le
l'écologie sociale Benoît Hamon est
accompagné de plusieurs candidats de la
Ligue génération point S notamment
Guillaume Balas et Salah Amokrane il
défend d'une Europe sociale et
écologiste Le Smic européen avec un Smig
à 60% du salaire moyen donc avec un
objectif de 1350 euros net c'est
parfaitement possible et l'Europe peut y
contribuer de manière très concrète en
faveur d'un printemps européen Benoît
Hamon compte soutenir l'ex-ministre des
Finances Grecs Yanis varufakis pour
prendre la tête de la Commission
européenne